äh decken so weit
der sogenannte Westen
formell gibt das dort natürlich keine
Einheit das heißt klar dass er sein sehr
komplexes Konglomerat ist aber trotzdem
sagen wir um das mal so dieser Westen
hat in den letzten Jahren und
insbesondere in den letzten Monaten eine
Reihe von Schritten zu Verschärfung
unternommen eigentlich spielen Sie immer
auf Verschärfung auch das ist nichts
Neues
dazu gehören das Schüren des Krieges in
der Ukraine Provokationen rund um Taiwan
und den Destabilisierung der globalen
Lebensmittel und Energiemärkte
letzteres geschah natürlich nicht
absichtlich daran besteht kein Zweifel
sondern aufgrund einer Reihe von
systematischen Fehlern genau jener
westlichen Regierungen die ich bereits
erwähnt habe und wie wir jetzt sehen
können kann auch noch die Zerstörung der
europäischen gaspipelinees hinzu das ist
jetzt wirklich ungeheuerlich aber
nichtsdestotrotz
können wir jetzt Zeugen dieser traurigen
Ereignisse die Weltherrschaft ist gerade
das was dieser sogenannte Westen aufs
Spiel gesetzt hat aber dieses Spiel ist
zweifellos in gefährliches blutiges und
ich würde sagen schmutziges Spiel es
leugnet die Souveränität von Ländern und
Völkern ihre Identität und
Einzigartigkeit und legt keinen Wert auf
die Interessen anderer Staaten zumindest
auch wenn das nicht ausdrücklich
geleugnet wird wird das in der Praxis so
gehandhabt
niemand außer denjenigen die genau diese
von mir erwähnten Regeln formulieren hat
das Recht seine eigene Identität zu
entwickeln alle anderen müssen sich noch
eben diesen Regeln richten in diesem
Zusammenhang erinnere ich an die
Vorschläge zur Vertrauensbildung und zum
Aufbau einer Systems der kollektiven
Sicherheit die Russland seinen
westlichen Partnern unterbreitet hat im
Dezember letzten Jahres wurden sie
wieder einmal einfach beiseite geschoben
aber in der heutigen Welt ist das kaum
möglich Probleme auszusitzen wer den
Wind sät wird wie man so schön sagt den
Sturm ernten die Krise ist wirklich
global geworden sie betrifft jeden man
sollte sich da keinerlei Illusionen
machen die Menschheit hat jetzt im
Wesentlichen zwei Möglichkeiten entweder
die Probleme weiter anzuhäufen die uns
alle unweigerlich erdrücken werden oder
doch gemeinsam nach Lösungen zu suchen
die so unvollkommen sie auch sein mögen
funktionieren und die unsere Welt
Fehler und sicherer machen können
wissen Sie ich habe immer an den
gesunden Menschenverstand geglaubt ich
glaube immer noch daran und ich bin
daher überzeugt dass früher oder später
sowohl die neuen Zentren einer
multipolaren Weltordnung als auch der
Westen einen gleichberechtigtes Gespräch
über unsere gemeinsame Zukunft führen
müssen und je früher desto besser
natürlich
und der Westen hat Terroristen auf
russischem Staatsgebiet nicht nur aktiv
unterstützt sondern dieser Bedrohung
geht vielerlei Hinsicht Forschung
geleistet wir wissen das und doch als
sich die Lage stabilisiert hat und die
wichtigsten terrorbanken besiegt waren
auch dank des Motors des
tschetschenischen Volkes
beschlossen wir nicht zurückzuschauen in
der Vergangenheit nicht die beleidigten
zu spielen sondern nach vorne zu blicken
Beziehungen zu knüpfen auch zu denen die
praktisch gegen unsere arbeiteten
Beziehungen zu allen aufzubauen und zu
entwickeln die dies wollten auf der
Grundlage gegenseitigen Nutzens und
Respekt voreinander
wir glaubten dass dies im gemeinsamen
Interesse liegt russland hat Gott sei
Dank die Schwierigkeiten jener Zeit
überstanden hat durchgehalten sich
gefestigt ist mit dem Terrorismus von
innen und außen fertig geworden hat
seine Wirtschaft bewahrt begann sich zu
entwickeln
die Verteidigungsfähigkeit begann sich
zu verbessern wir haben versucht
Beziehungen zu den führenden Ländern des
Westers und zur NATO aufzubauen die
Botschaft war immer die gleiche lassen
sie uns aufhören Feinde zu sein lassen
Sie uns als Freunde Zusammenleben
lassen Sie uns einen Dialog aufnehmen
lassen Sie uns vertrauen aufbauen und
damit den Frieden wir waren absolut
aufrichtig das möchte ich betonen
wir waren uns über die Komplexität
dieser Ernährung im Klaren aber wir
haben sie angestrebt
und was haben wir denn als Antwort
erhalten wir haben kurz gesagt in allen
wichtigen Bereichen der möglichen
Zusammenarbeit fast ein nein gerade
der Druck auf uns und die Entstehung von
spannungsherden in der Nähe unserer
Grenzen nehmen ständig zu und was werde
ich fragen darf ist der Grund für diesen
Druck was ist der Zweck was kann es sein
ist das nur zum Üben einfach so nein
natürlich nicht das Ziel ist das
Russland verwundbarer zu machen das Ziel
ist das Russland zu einem Werkzeug zu
machen nur um die eigenen geopolitischen
Ziele zu erreichen
und das Gehörte einordnen kann ich jetzt
mit Professor Andreas heinemann-grüder
von der Uni Bonn guten Abend guten Abend
ja Putin beschreibt was Russland in der
Welt tut das denkt man jedenfalls zuerst
dabei schiebt er das dem Westen zu wie
geht man mit so einer täteropfer Umkehr
um
man muss sehen der Putin adressiert hier
bei diesem waldey Club Experten
Journalisten Medienvertreter früher sind
da auch viel aus dem Westen hingereist
auch aus Deutschland heute sind es vor
allen Dingen Vertreter aus dem globalen
Süden aus Indien aus China die
adressieren will er will eigentlich die
Lufthoheit über das narrativ
wiederbekommen letztlich redet er gar
nicht mehr über die Ukraine
Genozid an den Russen und über
neue Russland sondern es wird gänzlich
verschoben auf einen fundamentalkonflikt
mit dem Westen und insofern ist der
Adressat ja einerseits das eigene
heimische Publikum an andererseits ist
so eine Adresse an die Intellektuellen
Vertreter des globalen Südens die ja ein
Gemeinden will in seinen Kampf gegen den
Westen man hat so ein bisschen den
Eindruck es ist extrem widersprüchlich
einerseits wir wollten ja Freundschaft
Dialog und so weiter wo man den Eindruck
hat das Signal ist wir wollen eigentlich
den Krieg beenden und den Status Quo
anerkannt bekommen spielt auf die Angst
des Westens natürlich auch vom Atomkrieg
an auf der anderen Seite macht er es zu
einem
fundamental-konflikt so als ob er
eigentlich überhaupt keine sag mal als
ob er
so ein bisschen Defizit an narrativen
hat also er muss ständig neue narrative
produzieren weil die alten schon gar
nicht mehr zu verkaufen sind
also er hat es ja gesagt der Westen der
keine Einheit bildet also in der
Übersetzung jedenfalls oder der ein
gefährliches Spiel spielt und der die
Identität von Völkern leugnet also das
ist ja eine kognitive Dissonanz die man
so verspürt
gehen da die Menschen in diesem Publikum
gehen die da wohl mit also er spielt
natürlich auf mehrere Dinge an mit der
Souveränität will er darauf anspielen
die Amerikaner beherrschen alle und ihr
sollt ja souverän sein und wir sind ja
letztlich
Russland an der Seite derjenigen die
sich wie alle anderen auch sozusagen von
der Hegemonie der USA befreien wollen
das zweite auch dass er anspielt auf so
Risse die es im westlichen Lager gibt
also es gibt bei den Demokraten jetzt
schon den USA welche die sagen beiden
soll verhandeln es gibt die
Umfrageergebnisse in Deutschland mehr
sind als 80 Prozent der Bevölkerung sein
wir müssen mit putinen die Gespräche
bald dafür
gibt die AFD die sagt Steinmeier soll
nach Moskau reisen es gibt Mütze nicht
der sagt auch wir sollen verhandeln also
es gibt so Tendenzen dass diese
Solidarität die es mit der Ukraine jetzt
in den letzten Monaten gab dass die
Risse bekommt und auf die spielt er
natürlich an die Villa ausnutzen da will
ein Keil reintragen wobei die ersten
beiden Beispiele die sie genannt haben
also die die Demokraten in den USA haben
das ja mit einer Doppelstrategie
verbunden und auch in Deutschland bei
den Umfragen ist ja trotzdem noch das
ist eine Umfrage Frage aber es gibt ja
auch noch immer den Teil der sagte dass
man die Ukraine eben schon unterstützen
soll ich habe er versucht auszunutzen
der versucht sozusagen mögliche
Sollbruchstellen oder Spannungen die
existieren politisch auszunutzen und
damit auch immer wieder
ideologisch Oberwasser oder medial
Oberwasser zu bekommen weil in den
letzten Monaten war das putinische
narrativ vollkommen zeigen auf dem
Rückzug also die Lufthoheit hat der
Putin absolut verloren und das sind
versucht sie wieder zu gewinnen jetzt
hat er dem Iran kondoliert wegen des
is-anschlags in Shiraz und hat dort
diesen Schulterschluss geübt man hat von
den iranischen Drohnen gehört die
abgeschossen wurden von ukrainischen
Soldaten und Polizisten was ist das für
eine für eine Schulterschluss den den
Pudding da macht es ist eine
autokratische Solidarität beide denken
ja dass die Proteste immer nur von der
CIA und vom Besten
verursacht sind das sagen die Iraner und
das sagt Putin eigentlich auch seit
2011/12 die große Furcht die beide haben
ist eigentlich eine Wiederholung des
arabischen Frühlings
Putin bringt sich allerdings auch in
einer Abhängigkeit vom Iran früher hat
er immer noch balancieren können mit
mehreren Spielern im Nahen Osten gute
Beziehungen zu Saudi Arabien zu Israel
zur Türkei zu Syrien und die
Abhängigkeit in die er sich jetzt vom
Iran begibt führt eigentlich dazu dass
er nicht mehr die einzelnen Akteure
ausspülen kann das andere was eine große
parallele ist der Iran möchte also
zumindest rhetorisch Israel auslöschen
und deswegen auch die Atomwaffen
bekommen und da gibt es so mit dem
Einsatz einer
potenziellen oder im potenziellen
Einsatz einer Atomwaffe eine Parallele
zwischen Putin und dem Regime im Iran
vielen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung und
die Analyse Professor heinemann-gröder
danke dass sie da waren